normativ und normativität das ist klar
sind kunst ausdrücke die in der
alltagssprache eher selten anzutreffen
sind
gemeint ist in aller regel etwas das
mehr oder weniger direkt mit einem
sollen müssen dürfen mit einer
unterscheidung sie richtig und falsch in
verbindung steht
das hat mit dem lateinischen wort norma
zu tun das mit maßstab und richtschnur
oder regel vorschrift übersetzt werden
kann
in der heutigen diskussion geht es
insbesondere sehr häufig um gründe und
zwar gründe die jemand für eine
bestimmte handlung oder haltung oder
überzeugung hat normativität liegt im
bereich von gründen deshalb vor weil ein
grund grob gesagt für eine handlung
haltung oder überzeugungen spricht und
insofern ist eine handlung unter dem
gesichtspunkt eines grundes etwas dass
jemand ausführen sollte analog eine
haltung unter dem gesichtspunkt eines
grundes etwas das man einnehmen sollte
eine überzeugung zu unter dem
gesichtspunkt eines grundes etwas das
man sich zu eigen machen sollte und so
weiter wie steht es mit dem element des
realismus
nun wird es wirklich schwierig aber in
einer ersten annäherung kann man glaube
ich folgendes sagen realismus hatte es
wesentlich mit zwei begriffen zu tun
der eine ist war und dementsprechend
falsch als gegenbegriff und der andere
ist objektiv ein realist behauptet in
einer ersten annäherung dass es im
fraglichen bereich mindestens dieses
wahre und falsche aussagen gibt außerdem
noch dass einige dieser aussagen und
hoffentlich auch ein größerer teil
tatsächlich wahr sind und dass diese
wahrheiten in einem bestimmten sinn von
uns als urteilenden wesen mit einem
bestimmten subjektiven standpunkt
unabhängig sind
mal eine zentrale frage ist natürlich
welcher sind von unabhängig denn hier
gemeint sein
wie ich deutlich machen möchte öffnet
sich an dieser stelle einen bestimmten
raum für alternativen zum normativen
realismus und dieser raum wird sichtbar
wenn man fragt wer von welchem
standpunkt aus von einer normativen
wahrheit spricht und welche art von
objektivität von diesem standpunkt aus
für eine native wahrheit beansprucht
werden kann
deshalb ist es wichtig sich zu fragen
wer von einer normativen wahrheit
spricht und wie der anspruch auf die
objektivität an einer solchen normativen
wahrheit einzulösen ist
damit komme ich zum aufbau meines
vortrags sie sehen das im wesentlichen
auf ihrem handy aus und da sind auch die
wesentlichen zitate zu finden zunächst
bei jung der ja schon mehr als einmal
zur sprache kam schaue ich mir an wie
die unterscheidung zwischen sein und
sollen in ein argument gegen eine
position verwandelt wird die man heute
als eine realistische position auffassen
würde und dann kommt ein kurzer nachtrag
zu formen des expressionismus die jungs
bild von sein und sollen in gewisser
weise aufgegriffen haben und verändert
haben wobei dann dieses bild mit der
begrifflichkeit einer realistischen
auffassung angereichert worden ist dann
schaue ich mir zwei formen des
normativen realismus an und zwar
einerseits canyons und kafitz das wird
natürlich sehr knapp werden
wir können das gegebenenfalls in der
diskussion vertiefen beide halten an der
standpunkt unabhängigkeit von normativen
wahrheiten insbesondere in bezug auf
gründe fest und beide bestreiten dass
diese annahme solcher objektiven
wahrheit in irgendeiner weise
metaphysisch oder ontologisch
problematisch ist das war die
klassischen vorwürfe gegen diese
position und die frage die ich mir
stellen möchte ist ob diese antwort
eigentlich tatsächlich ausreichen um
eine realistische position zu
verteidigen
und dann werde ich wenn auch nur noch
als ausblick eine alternative ansprechen
die auf diesen überlegungen aufbaut also
beginnen wir bei jung dessen hinweis auf
den unterschied von sein und sollen ja
sprichwörtlich geworden ist und auch
hier schon von herr keil einen genannt
worden ist aber geben wir ihnen die ehre
und die passage amex options konstruktes
what i'm surprised feind instead of the
jewel compilation des russischen systems
experte cent an
der riesen should be given for what
seems all together inklusive des can be
redaktion von the witcher in teil ii
tiffert vom 1 zitat ende
nur die passage ist bekannt aber sie ist
wenn man sich genauer anguckt auch
ziemlich undurchsichtig und sie ist
dementsprechend darum stritten
es ist gar nicht klar was ihm eigentlich
hier genau gegen sehen vor bringt und
was das argument sein soll
ich kann jetzt dazu glaube ich nur zwei
bemerkungen machen die ich auch auf dem
hemd out angeführt habe zunächst auf das
hat er gehört karl schon gesagt macht
ihm her auf jeden fall einen logischen
punkt geltend der das verhältnis
zwischen aussagen über einen sein
gs und is nord und aussagen geben sollen
in diesem fall der ort in ordner
betrifft und juden weist auf den
unterschied zwischen diesen beziehungen
hin der in der moralphilosophie der
tradition nach seiner ansicht gar nicht
wahrgenommen wird und bei der moral
begründung wird dieser unterschied dann
oft verschliffen das führt also seiner
meinung nach zu falschen zuvor lägen
schlüsseln die allerdings nicht immer
leicht als solche zu erkennen sind
was er da vor augen hat könnte so etwas
sein
insbesondere vielleicht aus der arbeit
strategischen tradition kommt daraus
dass der mensch so und so beschaffen ist
folgt einfach nicht ohne weiteres dass
er sich so verhalten soll und in vielen
fällen folgt es einfach gar nicht oder
aber ein anderes beispiel das wir vor
augen gehabt haben dürfte dass gott
existiert und das hat wird natürlich
geglaubt aber mal die annahme
problematisiert ist gott existiert und
vollkommene als menschen ist das zeigt
nicht ohne weiteres was richtig und
falsch
für den menschen ist wenn aus dieser art
von sein irgendeiner art von sollen
folgen soll dann braucht man auch die
passenden prämissen die ihrerseits erst
als begründet und dem zusammenhang als
low sich logisch schlüssig auszuweisen
sind das ist mindestens eine seite
dieses argument diese deutung trifft
also etwas was glaube ich im text
gegenwärtig ist und auch in der sache
wichtig ist aber das erschließt noch
nicht diese passage und das ist jetzt
der zweite punkt nicht anschließen will
jung weist seine leser in einer
bemerkung gleich im anschluss darauf hin
wie sein hinweis auf den unterschied von
sein und sollen hier zu verstehen ist
und dieser hinweis der dient sowie eine
warnung und gleichzeitig glaube ich dass
wir im hintergrund ein gegenbild von
sollen im blick hat das dann in bezug
auf die moral von ihm entfaltet wird das
ist das zweite zitat orient und das
folgt ein zwei sätze nach dem leben
zitierten
diesmal ist es passiv berieseln
zitat ende leider führte dann diesen
zusammenhang nicht weiter aus wir müssen
also noch mal fragen wie jung zwischen
sein und sollen unterscheiden will und
wer genau hier eigentlich der gegner ist
ich vermute dass jungs unterscheidung
zwischen sein und sollen hier seine
unterscheidung zwischen der vernunft in
den effekten spiegeln soll
die vernunft hat es grob gesagt mit dem
zu tun was als wahr und falsch beurteilt
werden kann und so sagt jauch an einer
stelle es gibt verschiedene variationen
zum thema reasons the discovery of truth
und erkenntnis dessen was wahr oder
falsch ist hat es in einem von zwei sinn
jung zufolge mit der wirklichkeit zu tun
und zwar entweder wir sagt mit real
relations auf ds oder aber relax ist in
san mateo fakt seine theorie besagt dass
unser urteil über das was wir tun sollen
ebenso wie unser urteil über das was
beispielsweise als last jugend gelten
soll
letztlich affekten zuzuschreiben ist
das ist die nation die in spiel kommt
und das ist bei jung mit der these
verbunden dass ein solches urteil keiner
wirklichkeit entspricht die durch die
vernunft zu erkennen ist die neue
beziehung oder behauptung die durch
wörter wie soll oder sollen nicht
ausgedrückt wird bedarf hier sagt einer
erklärung
sie versteht sich nicht von selbst sie
ergibt sich insbesondere weder aus einer
erkenntnis von relations of ideas noch
so wie er meint aus einer erkenntnis von
felix ist in sumatra fakt die beziehung
des soll und soll nicht geht über beides
hinaus und ist auch in diesem sinn jungs
worten neu und die erklärung die jungen
selbst für diese beziehung gibt stützt
sich dementsprechend nicht auf die
vernunft oder überzeugung allgemeine
sie schützt sich auch nicht auf
gegenstände die mit hilfe der vernunft
erkennbar sind sie stützt sich wie
bekannt ist auf effekte fans die uns
erst befähigen dies alles gut die soll
schlecht dieser tugend jenes als laster
zu sehen und diese deutung hast dann gut
in das bild das ihm im allgemeinen von
der unterscheidung zwischen tugenden und
lastern hat dazu noch ein zitat auch das
finden sich vor sich auf dem handy auch
dass ein bekanntes
du weißt in teil ii ist gelb zu essen
ist übrigens wieder
zitat ende
zusammengefasst die um wendet offenbar
seine unterscheidung zwischen sein und
sollen gegen eine position wird zufolge
die moral durch die von uns erkennbar
ist und verwendet sie zugleich gegen
eine position der zufolge die moral
beispielsweise in bestimmten ewigen und
allgemeinen tatsachen gegründet ist und
damit gegen eine position die in
heutigen begriffen als eine form von
normativen realismus eingeordnet werden
kann
die uns zeitgenossen beispielsweise
rationalisten wie samir clark haben
genau diese beiden positionen nicht
genauer unterschieden sondern ganz eng
miteinander verknüpft und genau das ist
die zielscheibe die jungen hier meines
erachtens vor augen hat
sehen wir uns jetzt jugend erben hat das
ist unter dem stichpunkt minimalismus
auf ihrem händler zu finden
es ist relativ leicht zu sehen wie die
jungs unterscheidung zwischen sein und
sollen in ganz verschiedene richtungen
weiter wirkt und im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert wurde sie insbesondere
sprach philosophisch aus aufgearbeitet
und auch neu interpretiert jung hat so
nicht zuletzt eine tradition des neuen
kognitives muss inspiriert die vom
motives muss oder preiskrieg tourismus
bis hin zu einer vielzahl von modernen
form des extremismus reicht und der
grundgedanke des expressionismus ist
ganz grob gesagt dass ihnen eine
äußerung die normative ausdrücke wie
soll oder muss oder richtig oder wut
enthält keine normative wirklichkeit
beschrieben wird sondern vielmehr eine
einstellung zu auch zum ausdruck kommt
die ihrerseits nicht sinnvoll auf
wahrheit oder falschheit hin beurteilt
werden kann
das kann man sich nach dem muster von er
lebe hoch vorstellen er lebe hoch ist
weder war noch falsch sondern ist es
ausdruck einer haltung gegenüber einem
menschen den man feiern will ist
vielleicht etwas schwierig damit die
anderen und fordo sie damit auf
ebenfalls diese person zu feiern
aber es wird nichts beschrieben und nach
diesem muster kann man jetzt versuchen
zu sagen wir sollten ihn feiern oder er
verdient es gefeiert zu werden oder wir
täten ihm unrecht wenn wir ihn nicht
feierten zu deuten und nach dieser
analyse könnten solche sätze nur so
aussehen als wären sie auf eine
besondere art von tatsache bezogen die
beispielsweise sein sollen oder ein
recht betrifft
trotz der dramatischen form des gesetzes
beispielsweise funktionieren nach
expressionistische analyse sätze von
dieser art eher so wie er lebe hoch
und jetzt sofort eine einschränkung zu
machen denn wie beispielsweise diamond
black barn und auch allen geber
zugestehen kann der expresso wirst
gleich ergänzen dass ein satz wie wir
sollten ihn feiern auch wahr oder falsch
genannt werden kann zum beispiel mit
einer minimalistischen deutung von
wahrheit die dann oft ins spiel gebracht
wird kann man das ganz gefahrlos sagen
wir sollten ihn feiern ist war das läuft
einem wesentlichen auf dasselbe hinaus
wie zu sagen wir sollten ihn feiern
es drückt einfach noch einmal genau
dieselbe handhaltung aus oder man
bekräftigt diese halte oder macht sie
sich damit zu zeigen dass man so etwas
sagt und das gilt im wesentlichen p ist
genau dann wahr wenn p und das überträgt
man einfach auf diese art von äußerungen
der dann sagt so ist es das stimmt und
das ist wahr macht sich diese haltung
selbst zu eigen
aber das ändert nichts daran dass in
diesen fällen dem ex boss sie wüssten
zufolge eine haltung in dem satz zum
ausdruck kommt die ihr sei es nicht
sinnvoll auf wahrheit oder falsch
beurteilt werden kann
das ist group die position
und bleibt man macht zum beispiel
denselben schachzug noch einmal wenn er
auf objektivität zu sprechen kommt das
kann ich jetzt nicht vertiefen aber im
wesentlichen bleibt es am ende dabei
dass die analyse nichts anderes als
einen ausdruck subjektive einstellungen
mit einem bestimmten inhalt der nicht
wahrheit fähig sein soll
beten kann das ist ja das
analyseinstrument und damit stellen sich
auch das kam eben schon zur sprache
bestimmte probleme ein
denn die einstellungen die in den
entsprechenden äußerungen eigentlich zum
ausdruck kommen sollen sind solche die
nicht mehr auf wahrheit oder falscher
hin zu beurteilen sind
und das wirft die frage auf wie logische
beziehung von normativen setzen
zueinander überhaupt zu deuten sind und
es stellt sich dann anders als bei jung
nicht mehr nur die frage wie der
übergang von einem seien zu einem sollen
auszuweisen ist dann stellt sich auch
die frage wie der übergang von einem
solchen satz zu einem zweiten von den
verschiedenen zu deuten ist wenn denn
beide nur vehikel für den ausdruck von
zwei ganz verschiedenen einstellungen
sind die ihrerseits der voraussetzung
gemäss nicht mehr auf wahrheit oder
falschheit hin zu beurteilen sind
denn logische schließen auch das kam
eben schon zur sprache jetzt den
transfer von bereits werten ein gültiger
schlüssen voraus und davon abgesehen ist
ganz allgemein nicht klar ob für den
fall in dem sich jemand auf normativer
ausdruck gewinnen bedient tatsächlich
immer so eine einstellung dingfest
gemacht werden kann
von der man dann sagen kann dass sie
wieder war noch falsch ist aber
gewissermaßen das wesentliche ist was
mit einer solchen äußerungen zum
ausdruck kommt da sind jetzt nur ein
paar probleme das ist keine widerlegung
ich mag ihre ihr jetzt nur einige punkte
die insbesondere die realisten
motivieren sich von dieser rat von
positionen abzusetzen
das sind also ganz sicher nicht die
einzigen schwierigkeiten dieser position
aber es sind schwierigkeiten zu denen
man aber sagen muss und die tragen dazu
bei dass insbesondere realisten diese
position zurückweisen und nach einer
bewussten alternative suchen
wie stellt sich das verhältnis von sein
und sollen also vor dem hintergrund des
realismus dachte ich komme damit zum
einem abschnitt 4
und ich habe allen eingangs schon gesagt
ganz groß wie ich die position des
normativen realismus hier verstanden
wissen will
sie umfasst zum einen den gedanken einer
normativen wahrheit der mit dem gedanken
einer normativen tatsache verbunden ist
natürlich muss man auch darüber noch
länger reden wichtig ist daneben aber
auch der gedanke dass die normative
wahrheit oder die normative tatsache in
einem bestimmten sinn von rein
subjektiven einstellungen unabhängig ist
ein kontrast kann vielleicht helfen den
gedanken etwas näher zu erläutern
beispielsweise gilt von meinem
subjektiven haltung und überzeugung dass
sie an meine biografie und damit an
einen bestimmten historischen und
kulturellen ort gebunden sind und man
kann den eindruck haben
das gilt nicht oder nicht in derselben
weise für den maßstab an dem sich
entscheidet ob dieser standpunkte nun
der richtige ist oder nicht
in bezug auf normative wahrheit stellt
sich dann die frage ob die wahrheit von
den haltungen und überzeugungen die wir
tatsächlich haben unabhängig ist und
wenn ja in welcher weise und das ist
sozusagen ein grundgerüst für einen
realismus den man dann in verschiedener
weise auch aus buchstabieren kann und
wenn das als gerüst die position des
realismus ist dann sieht man sofort dass
sich die frage der beziehung zwischen
sein und sollen in gewisser weise gar
nicht mehr stellt denn das sollen wäre
in gewisser weise selbst ein sein
es gäbe objektive wahrheit in bezug auf
sollen ebenso wie in bezug auf sein wenn
dieses seien zum beispiel als die
wahrheit in bezug auf die beschreibung
der natur des menschen oder der sozialen
welt verstanden werden soll
wir hätten es nicht mehr mit einer
kategorialen differenz zu tun sondern
eher mit einer binnen unterscheidung die
normative wahrheit von nicht normativer
wahrheit trend
und von einer form des normativen
realismus kann man sogar sagen dass
diese bin unterscheidung selbst
letztlich eingeebnet wird
da ist die idee dass das normative
selbst als etwas natürliches ausgewiesen
werden kann und das soll dadurch möglich
sein dass man beispielsweise moralische
tatsachen mit natürlichen tatsachen
identifiziert die das reduziere
realisten tun
man muss natürlich noch mal fragen was
eigentlich genau moralische und auch was
natürliche tatsachen hier eigentlich
sein sollten das ist ebenfalls nicht
selbstverständlich aber das ist das
modell mit dem man hier arbeiten will
unklar ist auch wie das eine jetzt genau
mit dem anderen identifiziert werden
soll
da gibt es verschiedene möglichkeiten
wir haben auch eben schon kurz darüber
gesprochen
auf jeden fall sieht man natürlich warum
diese art von position attraktiv
erscheinen kann
denn was zunächst so wirkt als wäre es
vom natürlichen kategorie verschieden
sowie younes beschreiben wird dann durch
eine analyse als etwas aus gewesen dass
am ende doch natürlich ist aber darin
liegen auch bestimmte schwächen dieser
position denn so ist jedenfalls ein
gängiger einwand zu verstehen
das normative scheint völlig zu
verschwinden und zwar gerade deswegen
weil es nicht erklärt und weiter
ausgewiesen sondern gleichsam ausnahme
metaphysischen vogelperspektive mit
etwas rein natürlichen gleichgesetzt
werden sollen
hier sind die moralischen eigenschaften
hier ist eine teilmenge der natürlichen
eigenschaften und beides kann man
miteinander identifizieren und man kann
zumindest da die frage stellen ob das
genügt um so etwas wie ein moralisches
müssen oder auch sollen wirklich
verständlich zu machen
viel einflussreicher waren deshalb die
versuche einen normativen realismus so
zu formulieren dass er nicht zu einem
reaktiven realismus wird
da gibt es wieder eine bindende
unterscheidung zwischen normativer weit
und nicht normativer wahrheit aber es
gibt nicht mehr den versuch das
normative auf etwas zurückzuführen das
seinerseits nicht normativ ist normative
wahrheit könnte man sagen ist sowie
generell und für diese position haben
sich dementsprechend bezeichnungen wie
etwa die eines nicht reduzieren oder
aber nicht naturalistischen normativen
realismus eingebürgert und ein beispiel
dafür wäre zum beispiel die imo der
bekanntlich behauptet bei der
eigenschaft wut zu sein handelt es sich
um eine einfache nicht analysierbar
nicht definierbare eigenschaft die mit
keiner natürlichen eigenschaft
gleichgesetzt werden kann und seine
erste folgerung drückt es so aus dass
die tat ist auch wm handout in bezug auf
die ethik sagte er
da der böse simple in the final jam
objectives ort bei reference to which it
must be defined aber was genau ist an
dieser gegenstand des denkens ist wenn
er denn nicht
natürlich ist er sagt zu dieser frage
denkbar wenig sondern werdet ihr die
versuche ab dieser eigenschaft noch
weiter zu erklären er unterscheidet auch
nicht klar zwischen eigenschaften und
begriffen so dass auch nicht klar wird
wir überhaupt den status einer
eigenschaft zum begriff eine eigenschaft
in beziehung setzen will das bleibt wer
alles vorkommen dass schwere er sagt
doch einfach sehr wenig dazu stellt man
sich aber erst mal diese frage und
stellt man sich die frage ob die
normative oder evaluation sprache auf so
etwas wie eine normative oder ewaldi
wirklichkeit bezogen ist die von der
natürlichen verschieden ist dann wird
man diese frage auch so schnell nicht
wieder los und es ist auch nicht ganz
leicht zu sehen die man eine antwort auf
sie geben kann ohne sich dann sofort dem
verdacht auszusetzen dinge zu erfinden
die es gar nicht gibt was soll das für
eine wirklichkeit sein usw
und deswegen glaube ich ist es so
interessant sich versuche anzusehen ein
nicht reduzieren und nicht
naturalistische realismus zu vertreten
der aber dabei von sich zumindest
behauptet keine metaphysischen
verpflichtung auf sich zu nehmen sondern
eben diese so weit wie möglich von sich
fernzuhalten wie das nur geht
und genau das ist die strategie des von
mir so genannten neuen normativen
realismus der unter anderem von scannern
und von parfitt verteidigt worden ist
schauen wir uns zunächst kurzes gerne
lang zunächst noch mal ein wort zu den
gemeinsamkeiten so willst gerne in als
auch parfitt geht es in ihrer
verteidigung des realismus nicht um eine
eigenschaft für die gut oder wertvoll zu
sein jedenfalls nicht in erster linie
es geht in unmittelbar auch nicht um die
eigenschaft moralisch richtig oder
falsch zu sein sondern es geht ihnen um
die eigenschaft die ihrer ansicht nach
beiden eigenschaften vorgeordnet ist und
das ist die eigenschaft ein grund zu
sein
weiter versuchen dann moralische
unterscheidungen und evolutiven
unterscheidungen dazu in beziehung zu
setzen
das fundamentale sollen die gründe seien
das kernnetz position in seinem buch wie
ingrid lästig war wesens unterscheidet
sich nun in mancher hinsicht von der
position die paar fit indem mehr
wendigen werk jeweiligen werk on what
matters von 2011 und nachgereicht
gewissermaßen 2017 vertritt beide sind
sich einig das ist normative wahrheit
geben soll dass diese wahrheit objektiv
im sinn von urteils unabhängig und man
kann wohl sagen unabhängig von
angegebenen rein subjektiven standpunkt
ist das ist von beiden die erklärte
zielrichtung der diskussion und einig
sind sich beide auch dass diese art von
wahrheit weder ästhetisch noch mit der
physisch größere schwierigkeiten
bereiten soll
die begründung für diese these fällt
allerdings unterschiedlich aus das
kennenlernen ist der grundgedanke das
ist eine vielfalt von verschiedenen
bereichen gibt domains sagte bei denen
jeweils eine art von wahrheit
anzutreffen ist
er sagt es gibt wahrheiten in den
naturwissenschaften das ist ein bereich
ebenso wie in der mathematik das ist ein
anderer bereich und eben den praktischen
denken ein weiterer bereich die nach
seiner auffassung nicht aufeinander
reduzierbar sind und die wahrheit in
bezug auf gründe wird entsprechend einem
eigenen bereich zugeordnet von dem
scannen annimmt dass er von den anderen
bereichen unabhängig und zugleich mit
hilfe der methode des reflektiven
gleichgewichts erkennbar ist und seine
zentrale these lautet dass die walz
werte von aussagen in einem bereich
innerhalb und nur innerhalb dieses
bereichs zu bestimmen sind
sofern sich bereiche nicht überlagern
und auf diese weise ein konflikt
entsteht
das wirft natürlich sofort die frage auf
wie man sich den status und das
verhältnis dieser gegenstands bereiche
genauer vorstellen soll
von scannern reagiert auf diese frage
indem er sie als eine externe frage
einfach zurückweist
er geht aber noch weiter denn er weiß
sogar die frage in welchem allgemeinen
sind die gegenstände eines gegenstands
bereichs denn nun existieren als ersatz
gegenstandslos zurück aber mir scheint
das kann nicht die lösung sein denn
erstens bleibt auf diese weise die rede
von den gegenstand bereichen viel zu
unbestimmt
um zu verstehen wie die these dass es
objektive normative wahrheit in bezug
auf gründe gibt damit genau eingelöst
werden sollen man kriegt als auch nichts
weiter dazu gesagt
außerdem ist nicht ersichtlich wie
erkenntnis in bezug auf die
verschiedenen bereichen möglich ist mir
scheint der bloße hinweis darauf dass
man sich in ein relativ reflektiert
präsentiert das gleichgewicht seiner
überzeugung begeben kann das reicht noch
nicht aus um zu erklären dass man da
einen gewissen verfügt auch das bleibt
schwer zu greifen und am ende glaube ich
wird es einfach dogmatisch die fragen
abzuschneiden die den status von
gegenstands bereichen oder das
verhältnis von einem gegenstand bereich
zu anderen betreffen
und ich glaube dass diese konzeption
deshalb ihren einspruch nicht einlösen
kann uns davon zu überzeugen dass es
hier keine app systemischen und
metaphysischen probleme gibt also
unabhängig ausgewiesen und erkennbar
sind diese normativen relation nicht und
es bleibt ungeklärt was uns dann
berechtigt anzunehmen dass es sie
tatsächlich gibt
gucken wir uns jetzt paar federn ersten
abschnitt sechs partien spricht im
gegensatz zu scannen nicht von
gegenstands bereich und dieser rede will
eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben
er unterscheidet auch nicht zwischen
internen und externen fragen sowie
scannen das tut und er schließt
dementsprechend die fragen die sich auf
die art der existenz von gründen richten
oder ihren status betreffen nicht als
sinnlos aus das ist eigentlich gern als
strategie paffett nimmt sich diese
fragen vor und will sie beantworten
es bleibt aber dabei auch ihm zufolge
ist es weder ökologisch noch
metaphysisch problematisch zu behaupten
dass es ihr reduzieren normative
wahrheiten gibt
und jetzt ist die frage warum sein
argument ist dass sich wahrheit ohne den
verweis auf ein theologisches oder
metaphysisches verständlich machen nicht
das ist noch nicht das argument dass er
die these und das wird deutlich wenn er
folgendes sagt das ist ebenfalls
untersagt
strong sense to the deaths have no
positiv
gleich danach die kleinsten im player
die sticks ist in some ontologie konsens
zitat ende
auf gründe übertragen wird daraus die
these dasselbe nochmal ein bisschen
weiter ausgeführt auch das zitat finden
sie auf dem handy
der riesen sensation
er meint die fraglichen eigenschaften
existieren überhaupt nicht und haben
deswegen auch überhaupt keine
neurologischen status
wahrheiten von dieser art seien einfach
war und das ist einer seiner slogans
cruz all i need to be true aber das ist
paradox denn das problem ist glaube ich
wie berlin das nicht klar genug zwischen
dem anspruch auf die möglichkeit von
wahrheit einerseits und dem anspruch auf
die möglichkeit von robuste objektivität
unterschieden wird auf die der realismus
doch aber zielt wie auch immer wir den
anspruch deuten der zu einer solchen
objektiven wahrheit führt die einen
maßstab für verschiedene sagen wir
ethische standpunkte abgibt kann man
sofort fragen mit welchem recht ein
derartiger anspruch denn nun erhoben
wird
er versteht sich nicht von selbst und
ich glaube weiß kernen und auch ein paar
fit bleibt ungeklärt wie dieser anspruch
einzulösen ist
damit komme ich jetzt kurz noch zur
frage der alternativen blicken wir jetzt
auf diese diskussion zurück dann zeigt
sich dass ist zwischen ihm und dem
expressionismus auf der einen seite und
dem realismus auf der anderen noch einen
gewissen raum für alternativen gibt ich
werde mich jetzt auf einige wenige
gesichtspunkte beschränken und am
schluss ganz kurz mal auf jugend
zurückkommen sowohl scania als auch
parfitt würde ich sagen sehen etwas was
jugend nicht gesehen hat in einem
gewissen sinn nämlich trifft es zu dass
ethische und normative wahrheiten nur
wahr sein müssen und nicht zwingend
ontologisch oder metaphysisch
eigentümlich sind war daran ist das war
weit oder falschheit zunächst einmal
immer dann zugeschrieben werden kann
wenn die sprache die betrachtet wird die
entsprechenden syntaktischen
zusammenhänge zeigt das trifft auf
normative sprache zu es gibt so etwas
wie aussagen die jemand macht es wird
etwas behauptet oder bestritten wurde
infrage gestellt
er scheint bestimmte logische
beziehungen zu geben die ethische und
normative aussagen mit anderen verbinden
die ihrerseits als wahr oder falsch zu
beurteilen sind so stellen sich die
dinge zunächst einmal da und wenn man
jetzt eine reaktion beispielsweise als
mutig oder einen menschen als verlogen
bezeichnet und zugleich bewerten will
man kann es sich dabei um eine wahrheit
handeln die der wirklichkeit entspricht
ob sie wahr ist oder falsch hängt davon
ab ob die kriterien des fraglichen
begriffs in der gegebenen genetischen
sprache erfüllt sind oder nicht wenn sie
es sind liegt wahrheit vor
und es gibt keinen grund dazu dieser
wahrheit gegenüber deshalb misstrauisch
zu sein weil sie sich beispielsweise auf
eine geheimnisvolle wirklichkeit
beziehen müsste die es gar nicht gibt
sie bezieht sich einfach nicht auf eine
solche geheimnisvolle wirklichkeit
und für gründe könnte dasselbe gelten
wenn die wahrheit über gründe nur
voraussetzt dass wir in bestimmten
umständen bestimmte tatsachen als gründe
für eine handlung oder überzeugung c
andere dagegen nicht die entsprechende
begriffe und natürlich auch urteile
wären dann jedoch ausdrücklich unsere
damit an einen historischen und
kulturellen ort gebundene begriffe und
urteile und wir wissen tatsächlich zu
den entsprechenden begriffen
insbesondere zu den sogenannten
genetischen begriffen hat es
alternativen gegeben und gibt es
alternativen noch immer das gilt ganz
offensichtlich braucht politische
urteile die wir fällen wer wird diese
begriffe verwenden wenn mit dieser
überlegung etwas gewonnen ist dann kann
es in einer gewissen hinsicht wahrheit
im bereich der ethik geben und
vielleicht auch ganz allgemein im
bereich des normativen aber diese
wahrheit wäre dann noch nicht objektiv
in dem sinn der dem realisten wichtig
ist sie wäre dann nämlich möglicherweise
nicht mehr unabhängig von unseren blick
auf die welt von unserem ethischen
standpunkt der sich unter anderem durch
solche bestimmten genetischen begriffe
solche bestimmten ethischen urteile und
auch effekte und bestimmte haltung
konstituiert
und mit einer wahrheit könnte ein
bestimmter anspruch auf objektivität
verbunden sein
wenn es wahrheit gibt und in bezug auf
diese wahrheit glauben und auch wissen
möglich sind dann wird vermutlich auch
irrtum möglich sein
und in diesem sinn geht wahrheit auf
jeden fall über das hinaus was in jedem
einzelfall ausgesagt oder geglaubt
werden mag aber das bleibt immer noch so
kleinen diesseits der grenze zu einer
robusten objektivität das ist nur eine
grobe skizze und alles andere als eine
verteidigung einer solchen position ich
habe sie jetzt nur deswegen so
beschrieben um deutlich zu machen dass
zwischen den klassischen alternativen
expressionismus und realismus noch platz
ist und jetzt komme ich zum schluss
meiner überlegungen und will noch einmal
ganz kurz auf jungen zurückblicken und
möchte das tun um kurz zu überlegen wie
dieses bild von sein und sollen sich zu
seinem bild verhält zunächst eher übrig
sich darin die schafe unterscheidung
zwischen sein und sollen so wie jung sie
selbst gezogen hat gerade so genannte
dichte ethische begriffe wie zb mutig
oder verlogen haben eine deskriptive und
auch eine effektive dimension die in
einem urteil das sich auf die
entsprechenden begriffen griffe stützt
auch gegenwärtig sind aber es wäre
dessen ungeachtet möglich dass ein
solches urteil einfach war ist und man
kann so etwas dann auch wissen im
gegensatz zu jung ist diese sicht der
dinge auch nicht auf eine scharfe
trennung zwischen der vernunft und den
effekten angewiesen effekte können
selbst mehr oder weniger vernünftig sein
was das heißt wird er nur anders aus zu
buchstabieren sein
als jungs bild von der vernunft erlaubt
weil jungs bild auf wahrheit und
falschheit beschränkt ist aber das
scheint ein sehr verengt ist viel von
vernunft zu sein
und trotzdem es gibt eine einsicht die
bei jungen zu finden ist die in
irgendeiner form in diesem bild erhalten
bleibt und sie verdeutlicht dass wir
selbst daran beteiligt sind das ist
bestimmte ethische und allgemeiner
normative und evtl
unterschiede gibt auch wenn wir dazu
neigen diese unterschiede eher so
anzusehen als fänden wir sie einfach vor
jung sagt dass in einem seiner essays
folgendermaßen lautet die formel
de la constitution und fabric of humans
and im endeffekt zitat ende
im licht der diskussion des
expressionismus des realismus und einer
möglichen alternative zu beidem ist zu
sehen dass sich jungs prinzip erweitern
lässt
nichts ist von uns unabhängig wertvoll
oder wertlos
lobenswert und handelns wert richtig
oder falsch
unterscheidungen wie diese drücken sich
in unseren gefühlen und effekten aus sie
sind aber zugleich und wesentlich
begrifflicher natur und richtig
verstanden schließt das auch wahrheit im
ethischen urteil nicht aus vielen dank